-My first guest is an Oscar-,
Tony-, Emmy-,
and Golden Globe-winning
actress,
starring in the highly acclaimed
film "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Here is the very talented
Viola Davis!
[ Band plays funk ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, Viola Davis!
Oh, I love you!
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you so much
for doing this.
I appreciate it.
-Oh, my goodness. [ Laughs ]
-It's great to see you.
I want to talk
about your Oscar nomination
in "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom,"
but I want to quickly touch on
you have a new addition
to your family.
-I do.
-Yeah.
-A son.
-Congratulations.
A son.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Here's a picture.
Here's a picture.
There. Awww!
-Awww!
-That's so cute.
Are you kidding me?
-Bailey.
-Bailey?
-Bailey is his name.
-Whose idea was it
to get Bailey?
-Well, let me tell you
something.
-[ Laughing ]
That is a story.
Whose idea it was,
was my husband.
[ Laughter ]
My husband, of all people.
You know,
I married George Jefferson.
[ Laughter ]
I fell in love with my husband
because I saw a baseball bat
near his bed
and I said, "I love him."
He's like my father, you know?
And he was like,
"We ain't never getting
no damn dog in this house.
They tear up the yard.
They piss all over the place.
Fur."
And then, cut to this morning.
I'm listening to him
downstairs, going,
"Hey, my Bailey boo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I love you.
Daddy is here.
You my baby."
So there you go.
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
You know, the Internet
was going crazy today
because the "Suicide Squad"
trailer was released.
Congrats on that.
It's major.
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's going to be giant.
You tweeted it out
and James Gunn had a response,
said, "No lie, @violadavis is
so scary as Amanda Waller,
I was afraid to give her
acting notes on set."
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I channeled my inner child,
Jimmy.
-Really?
-Because, when I was a kid,
I was real tough,
but I really am not that tough.
I mean, I appreciate
what James Gunn says,
but that's one of the reasons
why I love playing that role,
because I get to cuss someone
like Idris Elba out, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Claps ]
I also saw that you're going
to be playing Michelle Obama
in --
-Whoo!
-Yeah.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's a new series.
-Yeah.
-Why would you do this here?
You have
to keep testing yourself?
-I don't know. I think it was
temporary insanity.
-[ Laughs, claps ]
I lost my damn mind
for about five minutes
and made a damn decision
that I can't take back.
-Yeah.
-Because the woman is a goddess
-and everybody knows her.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Everybody feels like
they want to protect her.
Here's the thing -- I'm just
going to do the best I can.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's what I say
to my daughter every morning.
I said, "Genesis,
let me tell you something.
Mommy is doing the best
she can," so that's it.
-That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
Have you talked to Michelle
since they announced this?
-Oh, yes, I have.
-Yeah? Good.
-I have.
For several hours.
And it's terrifying
because she's --
Here's the thing.
Sometimes someone
doesn't live up
to whatever image
you have in your head,
but when they do live up to the
image, it's quite frightening.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah! [ Claps ]
-You know?
It really is.
-She really does live up to --
She actually is that cool
and that awesome.
You're going to knock it
out of the park.
-Yeah, she's that cool, yeah.
-I love "Ma Rainey's
Black Bottom."
I thought you were fantastic...
-Thank you.
-...unrecognizable, almost,
in this film.
-Thank you.
-You had all this weight gain.
You had the hair
and...the teeth.
-The grilles. My grilles.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Making my grille.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
You were unbelievable.
-Congrats on that
-Thank you.
-nomination.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's a great story.
Ma Rainey is also known
as the Mother of the Blues.
-Yes.
-It puts you in the Roaring '20s
and in Chicago, exactly.
They did such a great job
with that.
And, obviously,
Chadwick Boseman as well
is in the film.
-Absolutely.
Awesome, Chadwick Boseman.
And, you know, I told Ann Roth
that I wanted a body like
Aretha Franklin.
So I sent her a picture
of Aretha Franklin.
I said, "I want my body
to look like that."
-Yeah.
-And so she built me a padding
and I'm telling you,
I never felt sexier.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Is that right?
-No.
-Wow!
-I felt like my Aunt Joyce.
Jimmy, I had
an Aunt Joyce growing up.
Aunt Joyce was beautiful to me.
She was over 300 pounds.
She wore the latest fashions
and you could not tell
that woman she wasn't cute.
She didn't have any problems
getting a man,
keeping a man, nothing.
-[ Claps ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-So, when I put on that padding,
I felt cute!
[ Laughter ]
-You were, oh!
You were great.
For anyone who hasn't seen it,
can you set up
what the movie's about?
-Well, this movie literally
is very, very simple.
This is the Mother of the Blues,
Ma Rainey,
who is in Chicago to record
an album with her band.
And this is a day in the life
of recording that album
and everything
that she has to fight,
from the time she walks into the
studio to the time she leaves,
and that is it.
-Yeah.
I think, you know,
you're amazing
in everything you do.
I'm a big fan, but I also like
Chadwick as well because he
-Oh, awesome. Beautiful.
-created this character
and you go, "Oh, that's a really
interesting way to play that."
-Yeah, it is, you know.
This is someone who's just
running from trauma, you know,
and probably someone
with all the talent
and vision in the world,
but doesn't understand that,
you know,
you can't reconcile the past.
You know, you have to see it.
It's just a heartbreaking
performance.
And, you know, the thing --
I just --
you know, I always say
I wish for everyone
that they could have just spent
a minute with Chadwick Boseman.
He was everything.
Like I said, not everyone
lives up to their name,
but this young man, he lived up
to his name and his reputation.
He was a beautiful human being.
-Ah.
[ Applause ]
I want to show --
I want to show a clip.
Here's Viola Davis
in "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom."
Take a look.
-[ Laughs ]
-Damn what the band say.
You supposed to have
my Coca-Cola. You knew that.
-[ Laughs ]
-I ain't doing nothing
without my Coca-Cola.
[ Laughter ]
-Just a minute, here, Ma.
You come in an hour late --
-You need to get
out my face, Irvin.
I told you,
keep him away from me.
-Mel, I'm tired of her nonsense.
I'm not going
to put up with this.
-Let me.
Ma, listen.
I'll call down to the deli
and I'll get a Coke,
but let's get started, huh?
Sylvester's standing there,
ready to go.
The band's all set up.
Let's do this one song, huh?
-Too cheap to buy me
a Coca-Cola, I'll buy my own.
Slow Drag, Sylvester.
Come on, baby.
Get me three bottles
of Coca-Cola, ice-cold.
Get y'all something, too.
Keep the change.
-Yes, ma'am.
-Irvin, get away from me!
You can wait 'til I get
my Coca-Cola.
Ain't gonna kill you.
-Okay, Ma.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Get the Coca Cola!
Who was that?!
-[ Laughs ]
-Who was it?
-You know, Jimmy, though,
you know it wasn't really
about the Coca-Cola.
-No, I know, exactly,
right, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh. You're amazing.
Viola Davis, everybody.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
-Thank you.
Thank you, Jimmy.
-Say hi to Bailey!
"Ma Rainey's Black Bottom"
is on Netflix, everybody.